beneath the crust below the mantle and
underneath the molten core is the hot
dense solid inner core of our planet and
scientists now believe it rotates and it
even changes Direction every 60 years or
so a planet within the planet there's a
very strong magnetic field down there
it's pressure and gravity and the
magnetic field that all have to balance
we can't drill straight down to the
Earth's center it's around 3000
kilometers through the mantle just to
the outer core but scientists at Peking
University in China found that seismic
waves from earthquakes showed the
Earth's core rotating but also slowing
down and that it stopped just over 10
years ago and appears to be picking up
speed rotating now in the other
direction so what could that mean for
the magnetic forces in and around the
earth there's a powerful but delicate
balance among the magnetic forces of the
Sun the Earth and our planet's
inaccessible interior a magnetic field
protects us from the sun's radiation we
see the interaction of the solar wind
and our magnetic fields in the Northern
Lights the study's authors suggest the
core rotation fits with the 60 to 70
year patterns on the Earth's surface
shifting sea levels Global mean
temperatures potentially tiny changes to
the length of the day an ebb and flow
between the inner earth and the surface
it will fall to the ground we've long
tried to understand the forces beneath
us it will fall in this direction toward
the center of the earth and when
Hollywood heard about it the core of the
Earth has stopped spinning well you can
guess how that turns out microwaves will
literally cook our planet without its
internal convection Mars lost its
magnetic field its heat and went cold
that is not happening here but if we can
predict the subtle shifts down below we
could ultimately prepare for the effects
up above though John vidali says much of
the science remains speculative these
mineral physics people need to explore
what happens at a boundary between the
liquid iron and solid iron it's a whole
range of possibilities of things that
might be happening it will take time and
new modeling to better understand what's
happening what can be said now that
we've discovered that the Earth's core
changes directions at regular intervals
is that apparently that's a good thing
Eric Sorensen Global News Toronto